宇宙どうも犬したですないというわけで
これやばいなと天気的には外に出てるとか間違いなレベルの後さなんですけどこんな
ぜひ難いあったするドッキリをしてみようと思います
結局年が付いていって
聞かれたら思えば聞かれたら終わりだのあのこんな暑い中僕の家に来る人たちに
素晴らしいドッキリをしてあげなと思います
なんといえばこちら冷却スプレー付いてどれくらいの効果があるからよくわかんないん
ですけども涼しいことには間違いないんですよね
[音楽]
危ないですね局所的な打ち方をよくないですめっちゃ冷たいよこれ取れっぽいできる
ですけどたくさん買ってきました
まぁ色々あるんですけど第1子ですねマイナス85度まで気圧がありまして
-85ドってさぁやばくねあべなこれ大丈夫ことに
うんもう2
ああああああああ
yama yama れいとうビームやがったからなんかマイナス暑そういうことが
ex ために一瞬だけマイナス85度だろうね
福コールも今ってこうちょっとだ服を着てね凍っちゃった号ちゃったすげー
ああああああああ
うわーすげーなーというわけで今日の打っていれば家に入るとしたらドアが
-80ことになっている時によってみようと思います家のドアの扉が鉄なんで
ズって温度をと持ちやすい熱いものでねすればずっとあったか欲しい冷たいものを
かければずっと冷たくなるのでまぁ今回のこの時いれば完全適正だと思いましたやばい
もうすぐターゲットきます
早速仕掛けていきましょう
病院は3日
[音楽]
外が暑くてなかなか来れない
ああああああ
ふぅ
う
[音楽]
えっ
box 2
ています
なにいっ
ん
おっ
ame
5ドアノブ-80ことにそれ嘘ダメだもう地球が次て食べちゃったんだって
冷たい線冷たい冷たいだけ戦争初柔軟な感じでもねーさんだよって
ホラーす
ホテルこれまで資料3はたんね待ってねーろんだからじゃないポンッ
しています
唯一でて版ツイッターね今回アーサー
a はいですもうすぐする際
ね悪い
[音楽]
[拍手]
voodoo
カフェ
冷たいっ
スーパーやばっ
ねぇねぇ
ni ん
進めたいんだよなぁアレス干しっ
嫌なら-85ですさっきより全然詰めた
あこれが c やばいガチでヤバイこれは皆さん危ないのでマイナス85度
真似しないように
グーク氷くれ前ジャンプわーやまぐっ
マッハ